شو الاقتصاد البلاد واحتلال الشوارع تهديد
اطلقه الاتحاد التونسي والعام للشغل رفضا
قانون الماليه لعام 2023 الذي وصفه
بميزانيه التقشف التي تنهج المواطنه
التونسي حيث دعى الى احتجاجات شعبيه عامه
لماذا نقبل بهذا الوضع لن نقبل وسنحتل
الشوارع من اجل الدفاع عن خياراتنا وعن
مصلحه الشعب
قانون الماليه الجديد
بنسبه
26.4% خاصه في مجال الطاقه والغداء ورفع
للضرائب على شاغل بعض الوظائف مثل
المحامين والمهندسين والمحاسبين من 13 الى
19%
اصلاحات الحكومه تشرحها وزيره الماليه
التي تتوقع انها ستساهم في تراجع عجز
الميزانيه
حجم الميزانيه لسنه 23
69 الف و 914 مليون دينار مقابل
120 مليون دينار قانون ماليه التعديلي 20
تونس توصلت الى اتفاق مبدئي مع صندوق
النقد الدولي من اجل حسبه انقاذ تبلغ
قيمتها حوالي مليار دولار مقابل اصلاحات
لا تحضى بتاييد شعبي